hello i'm wolfgang puck and today i'm
gonna show you the best chocolate cake
it's served warm it's oozing out the hot
chocolate from the
inside serve it with a little
unsweetened whipped cream
and maybe some berries and a little
powdered sugar it's a three star
restaurant in your own home and here we
go let me show you how to do it
i always use chocolate minimum 65
percent cocoa
which means a dark bitter sweet
chocolate look what i have here a
chocolate
82 percent gives you the chocolate
flavor
we're gonna get a stainless bowl and i'm
gonna add
eight ounces of chocolate add eight
ounces of butter to my chocolate be sure
it's not a salted butter and now i'm
gonna melt it all together
over boiling water right here put a pot
on the
fire bring it to a boil and put your
chocolate
right on top the butter and chocolate
will melt together while the chocolate
is melting i'm gonna prepare my eggs i
need four whole eggs and three egg
yolks keep your eggs outside for an hour
before
you can whisk them better okay now you
hit it and separate it
four eggs and three egg yolks see that
how i
crack it here and then with my tom i
just separate it like that
and now i'm gonna show you how to
separate the
egg yolks from the egg white crack it
open a little bit
and then you separate the two halves and
then you go
back and forth with your egg yolk and
put the egg whites on the side
just add the yolk if you have egg whites
left
over like that make yourself an egg
white frittata in the morning or an egg
white omelet we don't throw
anything away let's look into our
chocolate here
see the butter and the chocolate are
starting to melt can you see that
while the chocolate is melting i'm going
to add four ounces of sugar to my eggs
here i'm gonna whisk it with a hand
mixer this is a hand mixer can you see
that my hand it's a hand mixer you also
can use a stand mixer it doesn't have to
be really fluffy
all you want to do is be sure that the
sugar has
melted into the eggs so if you have a
little mixer you can do it if not ask
andrew to come to your house and he will
mix it
where's andrew he left me already huh
all right i told everybody out there
you're gonna come to their house
okay okay good all right here we go put
it on high speed
i'm tired you get tired at your age
now we're gonna spray our mulch with a
little
non-stick you also can use butter and a
little flour but
the nonstick spray works perfect i use
that all the time in my kitchen
all right continue don't be tired again
i'm working okay
very slow look how beautiful now keep
the kids away from that because they
will eat it before you can make your
cake i know that's what
we did as kids in my home when my mother
was making a chocolate cake
we ate half of the chocolate before she
could make the cake
my butter and my chocolate are melted
now we're gonna add
the flour to my chocolate and butter
mixture here
two ounces of flour mix it well together
you don't have to worry you sift your
flour before so you won't have any lumps
in here
while you're doing that be sure to
preheat the oven to about
350 degrees okay now you can see here
it's
a little foamy our eggs and sugar a
little foamy
not too much you don't want too much air
in there because if not it rises up the
chocolate cake and then
he goes down again and makes it very
dense so
don't over mix it i tried many version
of that
i mixed it sometimes until it gets like
a volume like a whole bowl full
but it's not good the chocolate is
melted and now we always put the heart
into the cold slowly
we get it see i pour in the chocolate
slowly into my egg mixture
get the rubber spatula and scrape all
the chocolate out of here
at home if you want to you can add a
little boost to it a little bourbon a
little rum
what should we put in here
whiskey so if you invite the animal to
your house
have a little bourbon ready okay little
shot of whiskey for andrew okay
another one i can smell it already the
realm of the whiskey good idea and a
little
a little bourbon in here with a little
ladle
i'm gonna fill up my molds oh it depends
how much you like chocolate cakes you
fill it up
pretty much or you can make smaller
cakes and fill it up half
if you don't fill them up totally it
just cooks a little faster
let's scrape everything out of here
no waste separate them nicely so we have
two
four seven of them now the oven is
preheated to 350 degrees
10 minutes maybe 12 okay in the middle
rack of your oven
while my chocolate cakes are cooking i'm
gonna make a little whipped cream i
don't add any sugar to the whipped cream
because i like the balance the sweet
chocolate cake
and the whipped cream just makes it even
more complex
again andrew needs the exercise
why are you laughing how did we know
our chocolate cake will take about 10 to
12 minutes but you have to check it once
in a while okay after five minutes six
minutes to check it
andrew did a great job with the whipped
cream here look at that
perfectly done you don't want to over
whip it because then you get butter this
is just perfect here now
keep it cold okay you don't want to have
it sit outside i love whipped cream
let's check at the chocolate cake all
right you can see
the chocolate cake is not ready but it
starts to cook you look at that on the
side here but the inside look at that is
totally
liquid still it needs another five
minutes the first time i made this
recipe was at shinoa
in 1984 after 10 years and i said you
know this
is uh boring i do the same thing all the
time i took it off the menu
you know what the guest said the first
one who comes in and says i have my
usual my warm chocolate cake
and i said so if you don't have it
anymore called me over to the table and
says
why you don't have the chocolate cake
anymore i said well i got bored
of doing the same thing and he said you
know what if i'm not bored of eating it
you shouldn't be bored of making it and
i said you know what you're right
i went in the kitchen and it has always
been
on the menu since all right our time's
up
see that the center is still undercooked
if you overcook it
no big deal now we're gonna let it cool
for
five minutes we wanna serve the cake
warm
but we don't wanna unmold it while it's
really hot it might fall apart
and now i'm gonna show you how to unmold
the cake we're lucky we had this spray
so if it's still hot use a towel
if it's not too hot you just put the
plate on top
and you turn it over now look at that
how easy how simple
presentation is always important so look
at
just the chocolate cake where it's brown
it looks good but
add a little color around also the color
is important to me
but also the flavor so the acidity of
the berries
go really well with the sweetness and
richness of the chocolate cake
you know a lot of chefs today try to
make these huge plates and put a little
food in the middle on the side i like to
have
a plate which fits right
with my cake i always serve it with
whipped cream
you can see we have a perfect cream here
and then we take a spoonful of that
we put it on top
a little powdered sugar and here we go
our perfect
chocolate cake but the surprise is
inside
now coming close here look at that see
that
that's the exactly the right way
perfectly cooked
you can do that at home it's simple and
easy
you can make it in advance and then just
heat it up for a few minutes and you're
gonna have the perfect chocolate cake
each time and everybody loves that
dessert
perfect the dark chocolate makes all the
difference so there you have it my
favorite chocolate cake
and it will be your favorite chocolate
cake too if you want to know more about
me
check out wolfgang the documentary on
disney plus
you